if not las vegas' has been home to
important friendly matches in
international soccer the
mexican team has previously played
teams from the ms teams from the liga
mx real madrid has been here with
cristiano ronaldo but nothing is the same
as a match  official and although the final
of the lix cap a couple of years ago was an
official game of an invented tournament
this is a tournament that is the most
important in the concacaf area
for their teams so being able to
host the city of las vegas is  something
important not only for the
soccer community but for the entire
community of las vegas' to have events
of this importance just a few months
after the stadium was opened to the
public is something huge the
big games were going to dallas where there is
milk in sister  Jamal, who likes more than
100,000 people, went to Los Angeles
where they have the Rose Bowl, who can
get more than 80,000 fans, they go to
cities where they have real estate  from the
first world and now las vegas' is one
of societies thanks to the allianz stadium
although before they came to the sandwich they would
not bring such important matches I
do not want to minimize the case of real madrid
against saints but for the
future real madrid with all due respect to
Santos is not going to play against Santos in
Las Vegas, they are going to play against
Barcelona against Manchester United,
Manchester City because there is a
stadium where they can put more than
60 thousand fans and where they are going to
pay a good price.  ticket fans to
enter the game then the stadium to
midgets changes things completely
for the city of las vegas because they are going to
go from having friendly
matches exhibition matches
with low-level teams to having the cons
important elections the same mexico is not
going to  playing iceland here in las
vegas is going to play higher
ranked opponents the next time they are here
in las vegas' for an
exhibition match  ion